there's a little bit of controversy
between you and Apple CEO Tim Cook do
you want to is it worth getting into it
all or just tell people what it was yeah
sure what happened was Tim Cook was on
Stephen Colbert show yeah
and said that he hasn't seen the movie
but anytime you begin a sentence that
way it's not gonna end well he hasn't
seen the movie but he thinks it's
opportunistic and that it rip doesn't
represent a good part of the world he
said anyone make a filmmakers that make
movies about Steve Jobs opportunistic
that's right and I the next day I think
I just got back from London where we
were doing a press junket so you know
there was an opportunity to speak to a
couple of hundred reporters and I was
being asked about it I had said I
pointed out that it wasn't an act of
opportunism at all this was a labor of
love that that we all did and then I
mentioned something about the labor
conditions it has factories in China and
perhaps that was a better example of
opportunism than people making the film
I didn't mean to rekindle but let me say
this I apologize the next day and the
reason why I apologize is that Tim Cook
and Steve Jobs were very close friends
and I absolutely understand the man
protecting the memory and the legacy of
his friend so I get that too and so it's
all good now it's all cool it's it's
cool with me I'm not sure if it's cool
with with a building full of people in
Cupertino who all know how to hack into
my computer I hope it's good I was just
going to say what could they do to you